the last season of Game of Thrones was
always going to feature plenty of death
destruction and chaos and it certainly
didn't disappoint with its penultimate
episode the bells which focuses almost
entirely on the long-awaited siege of
King's Landing with the end in sight the
series still has plenty of plots left to
conclude and it moved closer than ever
to the endgame with the final episode
just a week away the show is offering
major characters left and right let's
dive into who didn't win the game of
Thrones this time around
obviously gigantic spoilers ahead Lord
Varys has been one of the most
mysterious figures on Game of Thrones
throughout its run the best gossip in
the Seven Kingdoms Varys quietly pulled
the strings on the background for much
of the show's eight seasons even as many
of the main characters surround the game
I thought they were calling the shots
until the very end Varys was consistent
and pragmatic about who might be the
best ruler of the southern kingdoms and
once he found out that Jon Snow had a
stronger claim to the Iron Throne than
Daenerys Targaryen he went against the
dragon queen
knowing that doing so would immediately
put himself at risk in trying to do what
was best for the Seven Kingdoms the
spider signed his own death warrant and
finds himself at the mercy of Daenerys
unfortunately for him she has little to
no mercy left to spare and Varys dies by
flame the latest victim of the word
trocars
[Music]
Game of Thrones have been quietly laying
tracks for the Narrows to follow in our
unstable father's footsteps for quite
some time but the dragon Queens pivot to
Mad Queen still seems quite abrupt even
for a woman who's made a habit of
burning her enemies by the beginning of
the fifth episode Daenerys has utterly
despondent having lost two dragons as
well as are too close as friends and
confidants assure our moment and Masson
day she seems to have lost a compass and
she spends some of the episodes earlier
moments of threatening a Queen's hand to
Tyrion Lannister as well as trying to
rekindle the very man she had with Jon
Snow before they learned a secret royal
lineage makes him a more compelling
contender for the throne as well as the
fact that she's Assante
John although visibly conflicted
projects her romantic advances probably
because well she's his aunt a rejection
that steals Daenerys for a vengeful path
even though the bells of King's Landing
rings soon after that Aerys first
assault to signal a full surrender to
the new Queen she shows no mercy to the
city she sets both soldiers and
civilians ablaze in an ugly horrific
move that exhibits the worse of her
family's infamous impulses without her
trusted advisors Daenerys has run amok
and just to make everything worse
she's massacred thousands of innocents
in the process with so many citizens of
King's Landing dying in her assault
Queen Daenerys may not have many people
to actually rule when she finally takes
whatever's left of the throne
it seems that Varys was right to have
back to Jon Snow after all one of the
show's most highly anticipated moments
finally arrives in the bells we're
talking of course about the longer way
to battle known as cleganebowl the final
showdown between the righteous yet
Savage Sandor Clegane known as the hound
and his enormous zombified older brother
Gregor known as the mountain the two
finally meet in the red keep asserted
tries to mount her escape but neither
brother gives a second thought to the
Lannister Queen who casually sidles away
as r2 finally prepared to face off the
mountain tosses Circe's hand Qyburn
aside like a rag doll and kills him and
the battle begins after a brutal fight
to join which the Hound realizes he
can't simply killed his creature who was
once his brother he tackles him as the
building collapses leading both brothers
to fall to their deaths and providing a
poignant ending to the Clegane conflict
as well as the hounds character are the
three remaining Lannister's at Jaime
Tyrion and Cersei have spent the show's
eight seasons our odds with each other
more often
nuts but in this episode members of the
fort family come back together more than
once helping each other get through the
war as best as I can before the battle
begins
Tyrion frees Jamie from captivity in his
own camp asking Jamie to make sure the
Belles of surrender bring and convinced
Cersei to escape from King's Landing in
a dinghy Tyrion has arranged to have
waiting in a secret spot on the shore
the two also share a beautifully tender
moment when Tyrion tells Jaime that he
would never have survived his childhood
without him you were the only one we
didn't treat me like a monster
Jaime repays Tyrion for his help and
that his brothers urging tries to escape
with Cersei after he fights and murders
Euron Greyjoy so he can find his way
back to her side but they soon discover
there's no way else as a red cape
collapses above them the two meet their
deaths in each other's arms as the world
falls apart around them proving that no
matter what's the Lannisters not only
pay their debts but stick together until
the bitter end
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
Game of Thrones are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell to you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]